だいぶ片目が隠れてきたぞ
ん
[音楽]
か言うかトップ
窓はゼール日本のみんなワインのことは何も知らない
伝説のソムリエ
始めんでいた私は今回コンビニに売っていた vine を全部買ってきた
価格なんちょさーんえええええあーこれだけの量があると思って聴いて今後はわーたー
しーワインには興味があるんです昔イタリアーノにフラペチーノ者時とは後ろ愛を飲ん
だ事があったり
その城は伊那とてもと
とても美味しかったのってでも未上場員の知識が全然ね今台なのでちょりあえず今便に
売ってた場合ん全部集めてみましたこの前処理でワインを一つにするとトリビアいた
トレビアンナージャになるのではないかなと思いました
はぁ
はぁっええええええ
[音楽]
が至極の味わいエラーはいろんな地方から来てるわけで
あなたはフランスの米ドック地方から来たんですね
遠くからお疲れ様あなたはあなたは何とスペインから来てるあなたはフランスから来て
ますね世界各国の場合の頭一つにまとめたらどんな極小なワインができるなかった
今よっちしたぜ今回はシンプルで全部の一つにして飲んでみると思いますじゃあ本当に
値段はピンキリだね3000から300円
有料カートと同じそうだね当たっ速混ぜていくよ
この中に入れて行くよってルートミートスパゲッティとハンバーグ対処がいいですまず
普通にのみては
2 dp とハンバーグ+パケットいるみたい
[音楽]
あーなるほど酸っぱいなお酒は二十歳になってから the
そう美味しい入って来られないんだよ方もちょっとだけれますね
選手に泥じぇぷりまべー甘口のワインだっておっは君の涙みたいだ
まーすっ究明はこれはこれはまず1機のみできるくらいに美味しかったこれは高かった
気がするなぁ
トレースサングレデトロこういう仕様ながらたいって誰か言ってやつなんですよね
スペインで採れたみたいです
高井店800円でそういう類なのは彼らは間違いないで
でも大事な金たんじゃない君との時間差
[音楽]
大
とか言っているけど彼はこれ何もわかっていない顔である
君の瞳も果実のようなありいただきマックスむらい
すっ
wh
[音楽]
ん
じゃあ俺も君の心の栓を開けてあげたいもんだ
[音楽]
me
ああああ親父 new 早ツアー
是正冷静累計でジュールって言ってるって言ってれるるー
甘い所
頑張ってもずれんよっだからなんでこうなるのさ
俺にはいつもずっと生まれないよええいやいやそんなことないよ
きっと始めるならとってくれる言いますまあ感ゼロ
ああいやあ参加しおいしいことでしょこれだけがんばって猿覇者やれさせんだからもう
おいしい車視聴いただきます
はじめのこの顔はイマイチ
味の違いがわからない時である
[音楽]
んだ
ムンかもね辛くちゃま博打も美味しく館できちゃったわけよ
[音楽]
剣士ブログ親父ディストロロッソ湯も合う度合いに多いのねもう
ああこれは飲み屋そうだなぁアスパラのユニパックマギーやトマトバッターでつばうっ
て書いてあるからアイナーアッサーノと的場さばき食べたいな
[音楽]
ああ
マイナーここからはちょっとたカノンエッツだ子が多いのでこれを使わないとかたやつ
ばっかり言い切りただ見かけるよ全部開けばショットまずこれを9頃もうすぐ誕生日だ
なぁもう24長はせる
おっぱはい
よし乗るぞ
ボズれねえ部はちょっと多めに飲んでもいいのかもしれないね
ああすげえやっぱ酸味のレベルが違うこれが一番高そうだなパラシオデル金でグランセ
れるばますよね2009年モデルだ結構昔からみんな作ってたんだね
ありがとう微妙 ok はいというですべてのマギーが入りました
こちらがコンビニに売っている全部のマインを集めた最強の魔印ですこれが美味しいか
どうかは分からないけれども一つ確実にいろんな風味が混ざっているバギーをこの中に
は高い場合もあれば安い場合もあるおいしいは今レバーを
おいしくない場合もある後世界には良い奴もいれば悪い奴もいるよ
でもなぁみんなばと
人間じゃないか
薄茶さっそく飲んでみるで世の中の便利を追求したコンビニ ss とは
一番行員スタンディング近い形のワインですよ
いただきましょう
[音楽]
世界のみんな
ばい
すっうまいっ
はあああああ
me
あっはぁ